in honor of women's history month we are
excited to announce USA today's women of
the year list it recognizes women who
show courage and resilience in making
significant change in their communities
and around the world the 2023 USA Today
women of the Year National honorees
include former First Lady Michelle Obama
who advocates for equality of education
for young girls astronaut Nicole Mann
the first indigenous woman to travel to
outer space Sandra Day O'Connor the
first woman to serve on the Supreme
Court the U.S women's national team who
negotiated a landmark equal pay
agreement and the women of the 118th
Congress but also making the list is
Academy award-winning actor Goldie Hawn
she is being honored for raising
awareness around mental health in
children through her program called mind
up only on CBS mornings Goldie Hawn
joins us now from Los Angeles good
morning Goldie
good morning and it is a good morning it
is a great morning with you part of it
so Goldie what does this honor mean to
you
it means a lot to me it really does I
mean I was very surprised and uh at the
same time I got to really stand next to
some extraordinary and very formidable
women uh so it really made me extremely
happy and I feel very honored
Goldie you started mined up in 2003
because you were alarmed by the state of
mental health among young people you
know that's something we talk a lot
about now with young people but not as
much back then why was this something
that was really important to you then
well all children are important to me
because they're truly our future and
it's always been my you know what what I
have given to you know so it's my
philanthropy however after 9 11 I I was
very concerned about our children's
mental health uncertainty and all the
things that were going on then also
parents that were also uncertain and
fearful uh and uh so I decided to put
together a program uh that might help
them become more resilient uh what I
learned at that time was that children
from 10 to 15 uh were were already
committing suicide and this really
really hit me to the core and with that
I made a decision and that was that no
child should be doing that so I created
this program and I brought in
neuroscientists I brought in so a
positive psychologists practitioners
Educators uh and what I did was I put
neuroscience at the very top because I
felt if children didn't learn about
their brain and we asked them to learn
that it's important to give them context
much more into their emotions and to
understand how our brain works and how
to manage it so with that I I put this
together I called it mind up and it was
a very sort of disturbance at that time
because truly no one was teaching
Neurology in the classroom from ages
kindergarten through eighth grade but I
I just decided that why don't we do this
so we did it we tested it we researched
it and it showed incredible uh uh
basically uh benefit to these children
so I decided at that point that I was
just going to put this show on the road
and I did and you know it was a Fearless
act but I decided something has to
happen our children cannot cannot
continue to grow this way and I wanted
to mitigate some of the problems so this
is 20 years ago we are now actually 20
years as our anniversary and and mind up
has served well probably over seven
million children uh around the world and
with that it because it works and when
you teach a child about their brain
ultimately they now have context to
their emotion and they also have
understanding of the neurological
correlate to what is going on in their
brain which gives them much more agency
over their lives more resilience and
so it's very easy program it's very easy
to implement and it's a very successful
program and I just you know want to say
that
this is probably one of the best I guess
scripts you could say that that I've
ever produced you know I produced a lot
of movies
but this might be the best one and today
today who ever thought we would be
facing this kind of horror with our
children and you know there's no beds
there are no psychologists to help us we
don't have enough we don't have enough
anything Telehealth we're working on
working on all kinds of important things
to help the children but I believe in
prevention and we have to start talking
about how we prevent this and I think
every school should have a mental health
preventative program inside agree here
yeah we agree with you
yeah so there's no doubt about it
go ahead
no I said this is this has been my my
life I mean you know we talk about
movies and movies are great they're fun
and it was an amazing time in my life
where I was able to produce movies that
actually helped women and really talked
about some of the women's issues in a
comedic way and making people laugh is
one of the Great
joys of my life and I just wanted to ask
you about that I want to ask you about
being a comedic actress
um do you feel like you're a Trailblazer
because for so many people you opened up
doors
uh you know I I never looked at my life
that way
um that I was a Trailblazer
um however I think when you decide to do
things that are fearlessness
um because you believe in them then
sometimes it can lead to that I mean I
would benefit all women by saying and
and Men be Fearless about some of the
things you believe in and take action
and I did
um and that was then and now I guess I
could look back and say yeah make it
open a few doors at that time
Goldie and that's what you're doing
you're helping these young people become
fearless and and understand themselves
and the way that their brains work thank
you so much for joining us this morning
what a pleasure thank you
you can read more about Goldie and the
other USA Today women of the year
honorees in Monday's edition of USA
Today and on their website